[Music]
good morning everybody
my name is Alan Bernstein and I have the
distinct pleasure and honor being the
president and CEO of CFR the Canadian
Institute for Advanced Research welcome
to this symposium exciting symposium on
untangling the cosmos I hope you're as
excited about as I am about the event
today I think it's going to be just a
feast of great science about something
that's really interesting to all of us
who hasn't looked up with a clear night
sky and just looked at all the the stars
in the sky and wonder what the heck is
going on there how it got there I mean
it just appeals to all of us I think
this is truly truly a golden age for
astronomy for astrophysics and cosmology
just thinking about the LIGO experiment
last year and detecting gravitational
waves as one example of the the
excitement and the advances that are
being made today in astrophysics of
course an ultimate goal of all the
sciences understand the UNK the complete
three 13.8 billion year evolution of the
universe and the nature and evolution of
the universe is truly I think one of the
great questions of our time and it's
always interested humanity and we are
starting to get some of the tools to
actually address that that question now
where we stand in that enormous universe
the researchers you're going to hear
from today are truly really truly
amongst the best astronomers and
cosmologists in the world and many of
them are CFR fellows in our program in
cosmology and gravity for those of you
who aren't familiar with CFR we are a
Canadian based Global Research Institute
with almost 400 of the world's very best
scientists from 18 countries at the
moment whose work embraces everything
from artificial intelligence to
economics from genomics
the origins of the cosmos CFR's
cosmology and gravity program is I think
quite unique both in terms of its
longevity um and its breadth of scope
and in scope it was founded on the
belief that only by bringing together
cosmologists particle physicists
gravitational theorists experimentalists
instrumentalists could we make really
profound progress in answering some of
the deepest questions about the origin
and evolution of the universe
this unique multidisciplinary mix of
theory and experimental experimentation
has created a truly fertile environment
for for new ideas and it's just so
energizing to go to one of their program
meetings it's the same recipe that we
use for all of our programs we bring
together as I said some of the world's
best researchers and put them into a
collaborative environment our goal is to
create global communities top scientists
and give them both the time and the
freedom to come together and to take
risks creative risks in their science
test their ideas with each other and
make progress that none of them could
make alone I want to recognize the lead
the head of this program cosmology and
and and gravity dick blonde sitting over
here in the front row dick has been in
this program as head of the program for
15 years and his he has provided I think
unparalleled leadership in cosmology and
gravity not just for our program but in
the world and true dedication to see far
I also want to welcome our new director
of the program the R Howard Webster
Foundation fellow Vicki Caspi from
McGill University in Vicky sitting over
here you'll hear from both of them in a
few minutes as our new program director
Vicky is taking the program in new
directions reflected in its new name
gravity and the extreme universe and
maybe Vicky might tell us a little bit
of what that means when in her talk or
in the panel discussion afterwards but I
also like I also would like to thank the
Webster foundation for its generous
support for this program and thanks to
all of you
coming to the end to the Science Center
for graciously hosting this event and I
also would like to thank our affiliates
science Odyssey and innovation 150 for
their help with this event and RBC for
their generous support and I also would
like to thank Jay Ingram who I haven't
seen for a very long time so one of the
nice things for me is to see Jay again
for agreeing to host this event and to I
think
prod our speakers into a very
interesting discussions after their
talks I've known Jay for a long time and
and it's it's great to have him here
with us today and I now I'd like to
introduce Maurice bittern who is the CEO
of the chief science officer of the
Interior Science Center but before I
asked him to come to the podium I just
when I walked in here brought back two
very kind of different kind of memories
of this gem of a not just of a building
but of a place that's dedicated to
science for the public the first memory
of course was when my children were two
or three or four years old and I'm sure
many of you have the same memory and
watching them run down that hallway into
the ravine building and push every
button they could before they ran to the
next and so they ran to the next one and
what a great place for children to first
experience science and to see that Van
de Graaff generator with hair going up
in the air etc the second memory was I
was on the board of the directors of the
entero Science Center and one of the
great privileges of being on the board
of the OSC is you get to go behind the
scenes and and although this is a big
building a lot of the spaces actually
you don't see as a visitor it's actually
behind the sort of behind the stage as
it were with a construction of these
exhibits that can withstand
four-year-olds pushing them endlessly
until they get bored and go on to the
next one
and it's just amazing and maybe we could
convince Maurice to let us all have a
tour behind the scene some point today
so Maurice thank you for hosting us
today and it's great to see you again
Thank You Allen and welcome back to the
entire Science Center good morning
everyone
it's my pleasure to welcome you to the
Ontario Science Centre Bonjour Madame
Amy csdf receive a booster shot of us
Bienvenue ce o Santoli science tell
ontario we are delighted to welcome the
Canadian Institute for Advanced Research
it's President Alan Burstyn the
distinguished researchers that will
unveil the secrets of the cosmos for us
today
je Ingram welcome back to a science
center as well but most of all you the
interested public that's what we are
about and the Ontario Science Centre has
welcomed over 51 million curious
visitors since it opened its doors in
1969 and we're constantly looking for
new ways to engage the public in the
thrill of discovery when you come back
to visit please make sure to see our
newest experiences discovery way and the
energy show which takes place in this
very auditorium that's why you see the
solar panels and the pinwheels on the
sides we also aim to be an integral part
of Ontario's innovation and education
ecosystems we do this by working with
research and education institutions in
the development of our exhibit and by
working with start-up companies to
present an beta test their technologies
on our premises our third strategic
pillar is to be a venue for the public
dialogue about science and society and
that's what we're so delighted to have
you here today for this impulsion the
Canadian Institute for Advanced Research
understands the crucial importance of
engaging with the public in the city to
discuss the significance and impact of
scientific discovery at the Ontario
Science Center we believe that science
literacy is a prerequisite for
meaningful democratic participation in a
technological society like ours at first
blush it may seem that cosmologies far
removed from everyday life but let's
remember that for most of human history
cosmology was part of mythology and
theology and that every culture on the
planet has some sort of explanation
for how the universe came to be but even
after cosmology became a part of
astronomy it didn't advance that much
until about a hundred years ago when
Albert Einstein laid the foundations for
general relativity since then however
the interaction of observational
discoveries on one side and theoretical
developments on the other had led to an
incredible incredible stride in our
understanding of the universe its origin
and his eventual fate
although the complexities of the
mathematical formulation of general
relativity and string theory have
conspired to keep the non-specialists
away from cosmology I have every
confidence that the cosmologists and
astrophysicists presenting today will
find the language to invite us and
welcome us all today
on the new understanding of this
wonderful universe we all share I for
one can't wait merci beaucoup thank you
very much
[Applause]
so I'm assuming that some of you in this
audience already know a little bit about
cosmology and understand that it's
actually awesome awesome in the old
original meaning of the word where it
actually meant something you know rather
than awesome deep-dish pizza or
something like that
and some of you may not be that familiar
with it and maybe not even convinced
that it's so mind-boggling but for those
of you who are somewhat skeptical I
would say just wait by the end of the
day you will have heard 12 outstanding
scientists as Alan Bernstein said paint
a picture of what we understand about
the universe and I think it's impossible
to be unmoved by that so you'll get a
sense of individual pieces of research
but at least a sense of how it might be
starting to come together I mean I'm not
claiming that the answers are all right
in front of us that's not true and never
has been but still it's fascinating
stuff you know I've had this book
cosmology plus one a collection of
Scientific American articles in my
personal library
from the time I knew Alan Bernstein like
1977 now that's only 40 years ago that
isn't a long time but the topics in this
collection are so different from the
topics that you're going to hear about
today
so then quasars were a sensation the
question was would the universe expand
forever another question was the search
for unambiguous evidence of a black hole
but now you're going to get the same
over the next few hours you're going to
get this same sort of sense of exploring
what we know but instead of quasars
we're gonna have pulsars and fast radio
bursts rather than searching for a black
hole we're going to look at the evidence
for gravitational waves produced when
two black holes collide and expansion of
the universe has been deeply complicated
by the discovery of something called
dark energy and you know the thing about
cosmology that fascinates me is that
there's this amazingly interior intimate
interplay between theory and ideas and
technology the ideas demand new
technology to be able to derive answers
raised by those theories the technology
in turn finds things that challenge the
ideas and I don't know of another
science where they're so closely
interlocked and you're going to get so
you're going to hear some fantastic
evidence of that today so you'll note
the program is four segments three
speakers in each each will speak for a
few minutes and then we will have a
panel discussion but also that really is
a question and answer period so you'll
get to ask questions of each group of
three researchers first segment is
called the cosmic background and you
should understand the word background I
think in two senses one the first three
speakers will provide a kind of thought
background for the rest of the day this
is kind of a big picture of the universe
but of course cosmic background also
refers to the Cosmic Microwave
Background
discovered in the 1960s that has really
set cosmology on a different path its
discoveries one of my favorite stories
from cosmology to scientists in the u.s.
we're trying to fit out a radio
telescope for Astrophysical experiments
and they had this annoying bit of static
that they couldn't get rid of they even
wondered if it were pigeons nesting in
the mouths of the radio telescope it was
the first time and perhaps the last time
in history that pigeon [ __ ] was referred
to as a white dielectric material anyway
it wasn't pigeons and the cosmic
background radiation has been described
by Nobel laureate Edward Percel as it
just may be the most important thing
anybody has ever seen
it'd be hard to start the day better
than that our first speaker is dr. dick
bond I was going to say some of the
things that Alan said so I won't I will
just say this in the movie The Big
Lebowski the dude is referred to as a
man for his time and place now
I'm not comparing dick bond to the dude
but I think it's fair to say that dick
bond who's led this program for 15 years
is a man for his time and place please
welcome dick ball
[Applause]